we act like victims it's the economy to
market the place I live the city the
place I grew up to school I want to
everything is somebody else's fault
because most of the world doesn't care
about wanting to fully found the secrets
about business and life and
entrepreneurship they want to be
entertained moral authority is when you
walk into whom everybody listens because
you have moral authority because you
work the hardest in your office because
you're reading the books cuz you're
leading the family cuz you're doing this
stuff that you tell other people to do
need motivation watch the top ten with
believe nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I wanna see exploded onto the
world so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew on today's lessons from
a man who went from fleeing Iran when he
was 10 years old during the Iranian
Revolution to come into an America
starting the PHP agency' and the value
tainment youtube channel with the goal
to inspire people to achieve their
dreams
he's Patric by David and here's my take
on his top ten Rose a success vol 2 joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one stick to the fundamentals see
when I first got started into business I
was all into listening to all these
motivational tapes listen I got a hold
of every single one of them and I
listened to him over and over and over
and over and I was just so motive and I
wanted to motivate everybody motive a
motive ah you know it was all I want to
motivate every single person I come
across and then finally got to polarize
it pad one if all you do is motivate
somebody they walk away excited and they
don't do anything about it
what are you really motivating people
for for your own self-satisfaction so
people say oh my gosh what a great nice
message you just gave you such an
amazing motivational speaker I cannot
believe you speak that way then it came
to a point where I matured as a person
that I no longer needed the attention
for people to say Pat you're amazing
don't get me wrong I love getting
recognition for my kids I love getting
recognition for my wife for my family
for my blood
and from the people I work with on a
daily basis I love that but to get it
for validation eventually got to
porn-wise said I gotta figure out a way
to learn the fundamentals of business
and you know what happened I was
disappointed let me tell you why I was
disappointed when I seek to find out
what are the fundamentals of what these
massively successful people that was 20
to 23 years old you know what it was
they master all the boring stuff that
none of these motivational speakers
talked about on these videos they don't
you know why because who the hell wants
to know about boring stuff what what
video that talks about boring stuff is
really gonna go viral it's not gonna go
far watch this video today look how many
views it gets let's look at the
commentary of this video this is not
gonna be great video that's gonna go
viral you know why because it's boring
you're waiting for a secret you're
waiting for me to give you some massive
special significant thing that I'm gonna
tell you that's gonna change your life
this week no no it's what I what what I
challenge you to do the last week which
is write out your commitments and follow
through with it
can you do that for 60 months
can you do that for 60 months you can
you do it for 60 months because I like
guarantees in life and you know what I
know about guarantees if you stick to
the basic fundamentals and constantly
improve adjust adapt but stick to that
same activity over and over and over and
over and over again for 60 straight
months you're bound to dominate your
industry and if you do for 10 years the
industry is gonna know about you you do
it for 20 years the world's definitely
gonna know about you by the way nowadays
you don't need 20 years you need three
to five years nowadays but you do need
to show up and do the boring thing every
single there was the boring thing show
up on time early in the morning leave
late improve outreach bizdev collaborate
sell communicate challenge drive lead
technology track and accountability
these are boring things you got to do on
a daily basis but it is what it is rule
number two decide to be great do you
think rich people are special you think
people who are very wealthy became very
wealthy because they are just so much
more special than you are it's one of
the biggest misconceptions in the world
they became rich because at some point
they said I think I can do something
with my life I'm sick of it I figured
out certain talents of mine I don't like
this thing my life sucks
I want changes and they changed very
simple you can do that as well rule
number 3 my personal favourite compress
timeframes
a 1997 ferrari 301 when 0 to 16 8.1
seconds which today 8.1 seconds is a
lifetime but in 1977 super fast then a
1997 Ferrari 456 1 0 to 60 4.9 seconds
ok that's almost 25 seconds faster than
a Ferrari now a 2017 488 gtp goes 0 to
60 in 2.9 seconds super fast now if you
look at that trend we went from 8 1
for nine to nine so let me ask you let's
go to 2037 what do you think a Ferrari
is gonna be doing at 20 37 you think
it's gonna do is zero to sixteen point
nine seconds can you imagine point nine
seconds you may say there's no way into
oral here's point nine seconds ready set
go
you just won 60 that's point nine
seconds that someone back at eight point
one set four point naught is impossible
someone at four point nine said two
point nine is impossible and then
someone stood out two point nine says
point nine is impossible but what's the
point with this this is an entrepreneur
channel what point am i trying to make
is this a Ferrari endorsement that I'm
making not at all this two points you
the point is everything in your business
today and the processes that you have
whatever it is from selling from point
of contacts to sales from receiving the
sale to processing the business to
delivering the business to following up
with the client to hiring firing
training whatever process you have
that's tied to a timeline what can you
do to compress time frames meaning what
can you do to go from doing in a week to
doing it in three days to getting done
in the day what can you do to get it
from 24 hours to 12 hours to 6 hours to
3 hours what is it what areas of your
business can you completely compress
time frames in today take a sheet of
paper make a list ask what can I do to
make the process faster and those say
it's impossible they get a committee and
ask them to put input what can we do to
make this thing faster once you do make
it faster let me put it to you this way
however fast your business is growing
today it's not even close to how fast
your business can grow if you figure out
ways to compress time frames in every
aspect of your business that is tied to
process or timing you will be shell
shocked by the results you start getting
with your business
once you're able to figure out a way to
compress time frames rule number four go
above and beyond in a world of business
there are two different types of context
you'll make here's what I mean by it
there's a types of context you'll make
that'll give you referrals that'll give
you a good sale good opportunity you'll
be given a good referral maybe we'll
make 600 bucks on a sale or $300 or $100
or $500 or $800 and it's cool it was a
good contact you made I did there
from your they're introducing you
somebody that's gonna buy from you and
Anna and then there are people you're
going to meet and make contact with that
could completely change the face of your
business change the face of your bank
account the reaction of the banker when
you go to deposit or check because the
banker looks at you and does a double
take it's one of these things hi how are
you great I'd like to make a deposit
okay no problem hi mr. Jones it's a
different look at yet you know why
here's the look the look is a look of a
person who is super prepared and they
don't wing it anymore this is what I
mean by when I say two different types
of context you see Kim Wingard with
every contact you made and just kind of
treat it and put it in your account and
follow up and do all that other stuff
then you can meet a person that can
completely change you to a life your
business and that one contact requires
you to do more research
you can't wing that contact you can't
copy/paste a message and send it on
Facebook or LinkedIn and make a mistake
and accidentally call somebody Tom that
was mr. Jones and mr. Jones was going to
be your biggest account and mr. Jones is
so impressed by you because you actually
research what mr. Jones does when mr.
Jones likes what mr. Jones is interested
in and what rubs mr. Jones the wrong way
and when you don't pay attention to
details like there were contacts that
are here and they have a lot more to
offer then 300 of these contacts
combined together you lose and the
reason why you're lost is because you
try to wing your way to the next level
and contacts at this level are not fools
they expect you to know what you're
doing they expect you to put that
additional energy into they expect you
to not wind yourself to the level of
doing business with them they are
insulted by your lack of research and
your lack of putting effort into it so
this is my challenge to you this week
whatever you do ask yourself am i
winging it or am I going a little bit
above and beyond am i winking it just
because I'm trying to wink it with my
talent or I'm trying to really do what a
1% or 0.1% we're doing this
and every time you catch yourself adjust
and ask what would the point one
percenter be doing in this same exact
situation and whatever it is adjust to
that rule number five
stop acting helpless you'll see a lot of
times people will say but but I don't
know what to do next I just don't know I
don't know what to do how how do I learn
how to do this who's gonna teach me I
don't have a mentor I don't have money I
don't have this look today we have
access to more resources than we've ever
had in our lives how to do anything
blogs blogs YouTube there is so much
access to resources that we don't need
to act helpless we act like victims but
it's not my fault she did it's my mom
you don't saw my dad my my mom my my
sister was this my brother was as my ex
my boss my it's just it's not my fault
it's the economy to market the place I
live the city the place I grew up to
school I want to everything is somebody
else's fault rule number six spend time
learning I want you to go on your
YouTube channel and forget about if you
don't have a YouTube channel go on the
search button above and click on history
and watch the last 20 videos you have
watched on YouTube and this is what I
want you to do categorize the videos on
which ones of them are educational and
which ones are entertainment if 50% or
more of the videos are entertainment
you're not really fully committed to
want it to become wealthy you're more
committed to become entertained and it's
not going to happen go on YouTube and
look the top 1000 videos keep going
until you find the first video that has
to do with a how to you know how many
videos are ahead hundreds if not
thousands because most of the world
doesn't care about wanting to fully
found the secrets about business and
life and entrepreneurship they want to
be entertained this is why Hollywood
make so much money because they know
most of the world it's full Aegis
committed to an entertainment that maybe
you go look at your search by the way
you can go on your history also on your
Google and look what works that you
visit and what you do with your time
that you have rule number seven get
feedback I called unhappy customers
happy customers you know my happy
customers do business with you it's an
easy call
you're amazing Patrick we love you
you're so great you always do this for
us you always do that's where I learned
you're just such an amazing person I'm
now learning there I don't need more
people to just keep telling me how
amazing how many people that tell me
these are the three areas that we could
improve it right so I call customers
that weren't happy I call clients that
weren't happening I called agents that
weren't happy I called employees that
weren't happy and I should tell me what
happened and they gave me so much data
you have no idea how much data they gave
you so much data to the point where I
got obsessed more with those
conversations than the conversations of
people that were fully happy and next
thing you know things kept getting
better and better and better I want you
to call three to five unhappy customers
and here's what the script sounds like
hey John this is Patrick giving you call
Patrick ooh Patrick wait baby you and I
did business to get about a year and a
half we're going to decided to go a
different direction oh hey what's going
on listen I'm busy well what can I help
you with look John this is I'm not
calling to sell you I'm not calling to
get you back into the business I'm not
calling you resale you up sell you
anything like that I just have one thing
one reason why I'm calling you I am
really obsessed with getting better and
you were one of my favorite customers
that I lost and so I just wanted to call
you for you to tell me what was it that
happened for you to make a decision to
go to a different direction what was it
and there's two things you're looking
for one you're asking was it me is it
something I did or the second thing
you're asking is was it a part of the
product the part of the product is for
you don't know what adjustments to
making recommendations to make the next
time the part with you it's permanent
this is an area where you can figure out
a way to improve yourself your game and
they'll advance you to the next level
rule number eight don't be too
conservative
sometimes a smart person comes in and
they've already been taught of certain
ways or their minds already been built
up in a certain way they are way way too
conservative way way too safe and in the
world of business sometimes it gets ugly
you know sometimes it gets dirty
sometimes there are some risks you got
to take you
got a taking it's not conventional risk
it's not conventional thing that I'm
supposed to be doing this no you can't
lean oh there's some times that you got
to do some stuff that you can't read in
any book or any video some value
tainment literally there are certain
things in business that's like what do I
do in a situation like this I'm working
on a book right now I'm flying over to
New York to talk to a handful of major
publishers because they want me to
publish this book that has to do with
specifically on how to process issues
once we learn how to process issues but
still if you're too conservative you're
gonna be toast in the world of business
there's gonna be times in business that
you have to do certain things that no
one's gonna think about but smart people
typically just go to to abide the rules
what they follow net loss not lost not
regulations rule it's a different story
they're afraid of breaking rules
sometimes conservative people rule
number nine listen to the right people
my parents raised me a lot of my
discipline comes to my father I love my
mom I love my dad I believe David I'm
what was him for the rest of my life but
my parents are not entrepreneurs and
they're not gonna be able to convince me
how to manage my money manage my
finances they've never owned a mutual um
they've never owned the stock they've
never been millionaires they've never
been rich what can they teach me about
becoming successful in my life by the
way for some of you that are so
connected to they're like oh my gosh
that's insulting it is not insulting it
is not insulting my kids let me explain
if my kid wants to be a professional
baseball player okay if he takes advice
from me on baseball on how to swing the
ball when he goes to the next level
there is a problem there I didn't make
it to the major leagues he needs to
listen to his coach I can be a fan and
tell him hey this is what a rod did and
this is what you know ken griffey had a
beautiful swing but I'm just a fan hit
that kid better listen to his baton
coach it was in a major league baseball
the same goes with business your parents
love you your mom and dad are great
believe me everyone's parents are mostly
great they did their best with you not
everybody has perfect parents but most
people are pretty good parents they're
not gonna teach you how to become
millionaires unless if they did if they
did take their counsel if they didn't
scratch their philosophies for business
go on from somebody that I made up and
rule number ten the last one before some
very special bonus clips get moral
authority
moral authority one more time moral
authority what do I mean by moral
authority this is what I'm talking about
moral authority is when you walk into
whom everybody listens cuz you have
moral authority cuz you work the hardest
in your office cuz you reading the books
cuz you're leading the family cuz you're
doing this stuff that you tell other
people to do
that's moral authority moral authorities
why people listen to what you got to say
there's a lot of people that want to be
heard on social media hey I'm gonna go
out and be a sales trainer I don't go
out to be a motivational speaker I don't
go out there and chill around Instagram
all these other things but you need
moral authority there's only so far you
can go without have a moral authority
moral authority happens when you're
going out to doing your part within
business you go self first you go show
up first you go finish the book first
you go and prove yourself first you go
change first you gonna lead first you go
do the work first you become veteran
collaborations you become better with
people you go do it first then everybody
follows because when you do focus on
moral authority 20:18 will not only be
an incredible year by 2019
you no longer have to focus on moral
authority because it becomes part of
your DNA and word spreads which means
anybody who does business with you you
get other people with moral authority
that want to do business with you which
is higher quality people believe me
those are the types of people you want
on your team so my challenge to you two
words go get a moral authority
now I've got two very special Patrick
David bonus clips around being a good
team leader and playing smart but before
that commitment of the day you just
watched all of this great content you
absorbed a ton of wisdom what are you
going to do now what are you going to
change in your business or in your life
as a result of all the Patrick's wisdom
leave it down in the comments below I
want to see what you're committing to
changing thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
your team-building how are you gonna put
a team together how good of a recruit
are you gonna be how good are you at
bringing solid talent operations systems
sales technology compliance how are you
gonna do that how what you're gonna do
that
team building you will face that
challenge where you're gonna realize you
can't do it all and it come down to how
will you build a team when they think
about risk-taking everybody falls
somewhere in this category of
risk-taking right you got somebody that
is so conservative they will never do
anything with their money ever invest
you can't even convince them to put in
the bank because they don't even trust a
bank because they believe our beginning
is around the corner you know any people
like that typically it's our
grandparents and they're so afraid
because of a lot of bad things that
happen then you have people that are
conservative I believe in bonds I
believe in having some conservative
balanced funds I believe in this I
believe in that everything is just
somewhat conservative and you have
people that are assertive they do
research they study let me look into
this Bitcoin thing what is blockchain
what is cryptocurrency what is this
insurance policy what is this stock what
is this doing house real estate this guy
told me about I'm messing to Austin
should let me look into Austin let me
look into Nashville let me look into
this community
Victorville they're talking about
California that maybe it's becoming
bigger because it's getting closer to
Vegas should I consider putting my money
in door maybe Palmdale well let me look
at this stuff but they're a server
assertive I'm learning I'm trying to
learn then you have the guys that are
aggressive you know I'm gonna go for
this and I'm gonna go for this and I'm
gonna go for this and I'm gonna go for
this
these guys they can have a big hit
absolutely it could have a big kid but
they can have a big loss as well and I
last but not least this is just
absolutely dumb category this is this is
the people that this is the people that
actually believe they can fly you know
this is this is like what was that one
song Mario by a/r Kelly remember our
Kelly
all right Kelly had a song and it went
something like this by the way this is
this is how he would sing if he was
singing to these types of people when
they invest this is what it would sound
like he would say he believes he can fly
he believes he can touch the sky he
thinks about it every night and day he
spreads his wings and crashes away
because that's what happens to these
guys in 2009
when a market crashed here's what took
place ford stock went roughly to add our
matter of fact it was under a dollar
imagine if you could buy that stock on
that if you had some cash set inside
what if you could buy think about if you
could buy 10,000 shares out a buck
that's ten thousand bucks
nine years later you would have 111 to
$110,000 $110,000 okay
Citigroup one not two nine bucks $74 to
be visiting went down to 13 I'm Warren
it is nice shirt went down to 13 today
hundred three dollars give or take b ave
went down to two fifty thirty two
dollars today that's 12 X 13 X Amazon
with 34 today it's 1500 now that's an
anomaly that's a different story
Nike was 12 today 66 I'm showing you
these things because this is not a 6%
return the 6% return means it takes 12
years for your money to double we're not
talking about that kind of stuff but
this happens if you anticipate a
recessions about to come up so having
said that let me show you some companies
that the companies here that have the
most cash take a look at this Walmart's
got 8 billion in cash today Procter &
Gamble 15 billion Pepsi 17 Amazon 30
coca-cola 27 G 44 alphabet which is
Google 95 Microsoft 133 Apple 261
billion dollars of cash is what they're
sitting on by the way this is from a
Business Insider article which was
December of 2017 Apple today give or
take they're at 285 billion dollars
today and I'm not even talking about the
old offshore dollars that they find out
how much some of these companies are
sitting on I'm talking money in America
that they have to report because their
public companies publicly traded
companies right and by the way something
for you to be thinking about Walmart
look at this number this is such an
interesting that it's a complete
different topic but watch this year
Walmart has eight billion dollars in
cash they get four hundred eighty five
billion dollars in top-line revenue last
year that's more than Apple and Amazon
combined on their top-line revenue but
they only have eight billion in cash
Amazon has four times more cash than
Walmart why because Walmart's retail
Walmart's retail this is why Walmart is
so war
about Amazon Walmart means 2.3 million
employees to function
Amazon only means 341,000 and Apple only
needs 123 thousand and they got two
hundred eighty five billion dollars in
cash the question becomes this for all
these people that say shouldn't have a
lot of cash
do you think the people in the boardroom
of Apple that say man let's have a lot
of cash you think they're dumb
you think Amazon Jeff Bezos is dumb you
think Tim Cook is dumb you think people
who run Microsoft are dumb you think
Bill Gates you think you know Google
guys said gay and all these guys you
think they're not that smart
you better believe they're very smart
now why are they stash them so much cash
away today probably because they're
anticipating recession to come up and
when this recession comes up they're
hoping a recession comes up because when
the recession comes up some of the
companies that make bad mistakes they
can pick them up on forty cents on a
dollar 20 cents on a dollar and that's
how they keep getting bigger and bigger
and bigger because they have cash so
what does this mean to you look let's go
back over here Mario come back with me
over here on this on this risk factor
here I want you to know Mari I'm gonna
go back and come back I don't I don't
want I don't want you to think I am
telling you to be here by the way if you
do want to be extremely wealthy one day
if you do want to be possibly a Decca
millionaire 100 maybe even the B word
you do need to be kind of here you do
you have to take some risk that maybe
have a very big risk but at the same
time I'm not a fan of people who
recommend saying only keep 5% and out of
your million dollars 50 of it keep cash
everything else put in invested I'm not
a fan of that here's one not a fan of
Mario come back with me over here here's
one not a fan of if based on what I
showed you this is not a myth I'm not
selling you this this is facts this is
thirty three recessions and since 1854
it's a fat one every five years is a
fact 2008-2009 oh one ninety how long do
like these are facts these are not myth
these are not ideas these are not well
could a pipe these are purely fact if
you look at this
you be the judge of it based on
where you're at on that risk side when
do you think the recession is going to
take place you're gonna say 2025 because
in your mind you want it to go for
another 7 years where the market keeps
going up are you thinking back there
saying hmm I think something's about to
happen and let you say somes about to
happen
great don't get scared about it you see
rich people are not scared about it the
people that I'm talking about they're
not scared about it they're excited
about it they're ecstatic about it
they're sitting on saying oh my gosh
this thing's been going and delaying for
eight nine years the longer it delays
the worse it could be now this is not me
projecting and saying I can't wait for
another one to happen believe me I've
been going 11 top line revenues quarter
as a company and we're doing very very
good I'm gonna be also be affected by
this but the message I'm giving to you
is realize cash is still king this is
not in the past it is still king keep
your cash don't get too aggressive don't
get too crazy don't go to the dump site
don't listen to our Kelly song thinking
you can fly you can't fly
nobody can fly but sit there and
strategize yourself to say oh my gosh in
the next year two years three years five
years something could happen and when it
does oh my goodness I'm going to
capitalize look somebody said well Pat
this and it's kind of deceptive I hope
everybody watches this video but they
won't you know why because cat videos do
better because somebody's sliding and
hitting their back and other people
laughing at them it just does better
because big butts do better because
six-pack just does better on videos
because pranks do better jokes do better
than a video this is boring this is
money and then people wonder why so few
people are wealthy this isn't something
new I'm telling you this is not
something I'm telling you Berkshire
Hathaway knows this they buy things on
sale they know this stuff very very
wealthy successful investors fully
embrace this concept the question is are
you going to embrace the concept are you
still going to be way too optimistic
about the fact that
everything's gonna work out because if
this is right in the last seven years
the longest time we've gone without a
recession has been ten years and it's
only happened one time and we're at nine
years right now
that's the recession so we got one more
year until recession comes are you ready
for the most important if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]